hey guys this is camera with motion
science and welcome to this video on how
to make After Effects faster I get asked
all the time how can I make After
Effects run smoother and quicker I've
got a simple solution for you today and
that is to work with proxies what are
proxies they are essentially smaller
versions of movie files that you may be
working with in your project let me show
you what I mean here in this composition
I've got one piece of footage which is
from Shutterstock and you can see right
here that the size of the footage is 968
megabytes
well working in After Effects with this
footage I mean it you know moves okay
once I start layering in color grading
adding graphic elements whatever it is
I'm adding on top of this footage the
project starts to slow down
seeing previews of our motion to the
line happening starts to slow down and
things just get chunkier so to speed
that up we use proxies and how we create
a proxy is very simple all we do is we
go up into our file in the project
window which I mentioned this one is
currently 960 8 megabytes we right-click
on that footage and we go to create
proxy still or movie in this case it's a
movie file you'll notice that After
Effects automatically creates the second
composition to render out this movie
file I don't know why After Effects has
to create a composition why it can't
just do that in the background and not
create a second composition in our
project window but that's how it
currently works so it doesn't actually
open up the composition down here like
it used to but it sets up the
composition to render with draft
settings and a file name
so we can go in we can leave these
settings the same or we can go in and
customize them which is what I'm gonna
do the most important thing is that post
render action is set to proxy typically
this is always set to none whenever you
do a render but it defaults to set proxy
which we'll leave as is and you'll see
what it'll do here in just a minute it's
going to put an alpha channel on here I
don't want the Alpha Channel it's also
going to use the animation codec which
is high quality codec but it's a very
large file size again so you can pick
anything here h.264 photo JPEG I
typically like to work with pro res file
so I'm gonna use a four to two codec
click OK
audio output is set to auto there is no
audio so I'll I can leave it on auto or
I'll let's go ahead and turn it off I'll
click OK and then I'm going to tell
After Effects where to save this file
which I've already got set up in a
folder here called proxies and I'll just
leave it the same name and at this point
all I have to do is click render and
it's going to create the proxy file
okay so it just finished rendering and
if you look back up in the project
window you can see on the original
footage there's now a gray box right
here which means hey this footage is now
a proxy you can also see that the file
size went from nine hundred and some-odd
megabytes to two hundred and
seventy-five megabytes so now we're
working with a much smaller file size
and it's automatically updated in our
project window I'm actually gonna go
ahead and delete this second composition
that After Effects made for rendering
purposes so there you go so we have a
proxy file in here and if i zoom in 200%
if you look at the edges here you can
tell it's a little bit lower res when I
click this gray box this is the cool
part is it will automatically go back to
the original footage instead of the
proxy and you'll see on the edges here
watch the difference on the edging
that's full res proxy full res proxy I
don't know how much of that you can
actually see in the compression on the
web here but it's a noticeable
difference and also you'll notice when I
click off the proxy the file size goes
right back to 960 a because that's the
original so proxy 275 original nine 68
and that's pretty much all you have to
do you can work with the footage down
here when you're ready to render you can
just shut off the proxy go to render
like you'd normally would and render out
a high risk file so there you go there's
the basics of working with proxies
inside After Effects there are a few
more things you can dive into with
proxies I'm not going to get into those
today in this video but that gives you
the essence of proxies and how to speed
up your After Effects workflow I hope
that you learned something new today and
I would love if you would like or
comment below and let me know what you
thought until next time
I'm Cameron and this is motion science